ich weine vor stolz pixum war wieso der
woche bei senders heim und das ist eine
der fragen hierbei praktiker ultra keks
kanone möchte wissen wenn du die
möglichkeit hättest etwas zu erfinden
abgesehen davon ob es zum jetzigen stand
der technik möglich ist oder nicht was
wäre es also ich glaube ich würde das
elektroauto erfinden oder das
umweltfreundliche fahrzeug das wirklich
eine riesige reichweite hat und wo wir
uns keine sorgen mehr machen müssen wie
weit wir kommen auch die batterien noch
reicht ich bin ja viel elektro auto
gefahren und bin das eine oder andere
mal liegen geblieben und das ist immer
ein bisschen muss man halt die steckdose
suchen
nicht überall gibt steckdosen aber ich
war dann immer noch relativ in orient
moya fragt mich wie siehst du die welt
in 20 jahren was kann da sein wie ist
die technik und medizin
was glaubst du ja es gibt den
pessimisten bei mir und den optimisten
der pessimist das sagt natürlich die
weltmeere sind kurz vor der überfischung
es gibt kaum etwas zu essen
die fleischproduktion ist komplett aus
den fugen geraten wir versorgen unsere
umwelt immer mehr und es wird immer
schlimmer und schlechter hier auf der
welt zu leben das ist der pessimisten
der optimist der glaubt haye wir haben
das eine oder andere in den griff
gekriegt wer leben gesünder wir schon
unsere umwelt das ist so wirklich das
wichtigste thema und es gibt eine
perspektive für die menschheit
hier auf dem planeten zu überleben also
die beiden pole die die habe ich und ich
hoffe natürlich dass es ne zum positiven
aus schlägt dann so dem 20 jahren schau
mal abends auf horner würdest du gern
unendlich leben wenn du nicht altern
würdest
ich glaube also versetzt euch mal in die
situation
ihr hättet nicht die perspektive zu
sterben außer durch
ein unglück oder ähnliches also ich mir
würde vielleicht ein bisschen der
antrieb fehlen um wirklich jeden tag das
meiste aus meinem leben zu machen was
möglich ist und ich halte den tod für
einen unglaublich guten berater und ich
denke jeden tag eigentlich an den tod
ein unglaublich guten berater um
wirklich den tag zu nutzen und das beste
draus zu machen
risiko etwas tolles zu erleben aber auch
um die welt was zu verändern um tolle
videos zu machen mit denen man die leute
aufklärt indem man sie informiert und
die welt so ein bisschen voran bringt
also ich bin also ich versuche so zu
leben dass ich jederzeit sterben könnte
also dass ich so viel auf meinem leben
gemacht haben und so viel bewirkt habe
wie es nur eben möglich ist und von
daher finde ich den tod eigentlich
schlecht und ich kann es mir irgendwie
wäre die luft raus so ein bisschen wenn
man unendlich leben würde und ich glaube
auch dass kann der mensch gar nicht also
deswegen empfindet er ja auch die zeit
so als wäre sie nur in eine richtung wie
gerichtet was ja nicht der fall ist es
gibt ja teilchen die in die andere
richtung in die vergangenheit sich
bewegen also und ich glaube das ist gar
nicht möglich das ist alles so angelegt
dass hat seinen sinn gibt ja auch ein
paar biologische gründe warum das so ist
alter der zellen veränderungen der gene
durch kosmische strahlung und so weiter
und so fort
also ich hab mir nicht vorstellen
dominik drews sei bitte ehrlich bin ich
immer warum hast du diese selbst
experiment mit dem alkohol gemacht war
es wirklich nötig ja also für mich ist
wissenschaft auch immer irgendwie selber
auszuprobieren ist selber wirklich zu
verstehen und gerade drogen ist etwas
was ich glaube dass man nur wirklich von
dem mann erzählen kann wenn man es
erlebt hat mit aller vorsicht natürlich
und mir war wichtig ich trinke
normalerweise nicht so viel das war ja
auch wirklich zu viel zu erleben was
passiert mit einem und das dann auch im
nachhinein noch mal zu sehen weil wenn
man selber sind war der eigenen haut
steckt da kriegt man das auch nicht so
ganz mit
das war schon unglaublich interessant
und ich kann sich weiter empfehlen weil
so eine menge alkohol soll man nicht
trinken nicht mehr für die songs machen
aber das waren schon sehr interessant
das worüber man redet auch erlebt zu
haben und von daher ich guck mal ich
glaube ich jetzt auch fortsetzen mit
anderen drogen und sofern man das machen
kann wenn ich möglichst viel
ausprobieren und davon erzählen
aber drogen sind absolut gefährlich ich
finde ich gut weil sie ja die
persönlichkeit verändern das kommt ja
auch noch dazu man ist ja nicht mal
selbst und war unser mann drogen nehmen
wir wandern anderer ist also macht für
mich nicht so ganz hin sender sein fragt
karten wie stolz macht es sich wieder
der woche bei sender diamond zu sein und
ich sage ich es freut mich riesig ich
bin super ich habe überhaupt nicht damit
gerechnet habt am rande erfahren und
finde das ganz toll und ich kann nur
danke danke danke sagen was ich auch
alle menschen sorge über video
zugeschaut haben schaut das letzte frage
das ist hier oben verlinkt da erwartet
man sich auch eure fragen stellt ganz
viele fragen und viele weitere news
informationen gibt es im doppeltrap link
ist da und was soll ich noch sagen alle
video links natürlich alle links
überhaupt sind natürlich in dem video
beschreibungen ansonsten bis dann bleibt
an